thème la france va-t-elle devenir une
terre d'asile pour le cinéaste woody
allen vendredi dernier le groupe
hachette a lâché le réalisateur qui
devait publier dans cette maison
d'édition son autobiographie mais cet
ouvrage pourrait toujours sortir en
france chez stock
si son directeur parvient à ses fins il
confié ce week-end au point qu'il ferait
tout pour maintenir la publication je
vous rappelle juste l'effet brièvement
co répond que reproche-t-on à woody
allen plusieurs choses d'abord d'avoir
épousé la fille adoptive de son ex femme
mia farrow de 35 ans sa cadette
et puis plus grave ni à faro l'accusent
d'abus sexuels sur leur fille adoptive
dylan farouk avait sept ans à l'époque
ce que vous dit allen a toujours démenti
après une enquête approfondie la justice
américaine a refusé de poursuivre le
cinéaste donc au regard de la justice
cet homme est innocent voilà pour le
contexte
richard bouhet qu'est-ce que vous êtes
rassurés qu'en france un éditeur veille
encore le publier je passe je suis
rassuré moi ça me pose quand même
plusieurs questions d'abord c'est une
analogie entre polanski et woody allen à
ce que je sache il n'y a pas de la part
de google ne souffre pas d'une
condamnation par la justice et donc je
pense que déjà cette comparaison n'avait
pas n'avait pas lieu d'être la deuxième
question c'est qui décide
j'ai un peu la sensation que là c'est un
peu les salariés de ces
du groupe hachette aux états unis qui se
sont mobilisés qui ont décidé j'ai peur
que un peu comme le disait stephen king
qui est le suivant parce que finalement
si à chaque fois c'est le tribunal
populaire qui décide de la publication
ou non d'un auteur ça pose un sujet on a
un auteur là qui n'a pas de condamnation
en justice pourquoi ne passe télérama
disaient les sont décidées les lecteurs
sur 7 sur cette affaire en tout cas moi
elle me pose un problème sur lucky
décider comment décider on pourra avoir
des deux poids deux mesures et là encore
plein d'incohérences on en parlait sur
le premier sujet mais on en publie
certains qui sont condamnés on en publie
pas à d'autres qui ne le sont pas pour
quelle raison est-ce qu'il fallait si je
veux demander son chemin de ses fils qui
est publiée par une des je crois à une
déco un des éditions quellier au groupe
hachette a demandé à ce que il y aussi
la voie des plaignants qui soit qu'ils
soient entendues mais les visiblement
lui-même a publié ce qu'on veut trouver
enfin voilà pour finir enfin pour le
service est un homme qui n'est pas
condamné mais que l'on condamne dans sa
publication
un homme qui à un moment donné à je
pense une biographie qui n'est pas
attentatoire ni à la loi n'est à autre
chose qui pose le problème moi c'est
surtout ça de qui décide in fine et et
dans cette affaire le fait que ce soit
non plus le fait qu'on ait un rapport à
la justice qui pourraient s'entendre
mais qu'on ait un rapport là juste à
tout d'un coup une émotion une
contestation et on y va
robot donc le fils de le fils biologique
de woody allen qui redonne pharos est un
pseudonyme et il a dit il ya eu cette
phrase hier la décision initiale
d'hachette de publier woody allen
témoigne d'un manque de compassion pour
les victimes d'agressions sexuelles
je vous propose juste avant qu'on
continue le débat rapidement dès que
d'écouter l'avocat pénaliste marie dosé
qui raconte justement ce matin son
inquiétude face à ces accusations d'
offense et de compassion de manque de
compassion mais moi j'ai peur là de vous
parler est ce que c'est normal
est ce que c'est normal que moi avocate
j'ai failli ne pas répondre à votre
habitation
pourquoi vous avez peur pourquoi parce
que je sens que la libération de cette
parole est en train de confisquer les
autres et qu' il n'est pas normal dans
notre état de droit qu en rappelant les
grands principes de l'état de droit on
ait peur d'intervenir publiquement et la
difficulté c'est que si achat
je rappelle l'état le droit les victimes
de violences sexuelles considère que je
leur fait offense on arrive à une
catastrophe
gabriel cluzel vous comprenez ce qu'a
dit oui évidemment moi j'avoue que cette
affaire me suis site des sentiments
ambivalents le premier c'est que vous je
suis plutôt contente qu'il ya un sursaut
de la société face à ce que
j'appellerais une dérive post soixante
huitard libertaire échevelé c'est à dire
que tout était ordre bourgeois y compris
ce qu'ils s'opposaient à la à la
pédophilie donc c'est ce que george
orwell a appelé la décence commune il ya
sans doute un tir de barrage là tout
d'un coup on le voit avec les affaires
diverses et variées polanski madness mai
mais en l'occurrence là il n'a pas été
condamné donc comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure
en effet on est face à un tribunal
médiatique alors c'est il ya une
accusation de son ans son ex épouse mais
une femme et ce serait le pire des
sexisme de l'affirmer n'est pas
innocente par nature un c'est vraiment à
voir je ne dis parfois avoir je n'ai pas
pu pas lui plus loin que martine à la
plage pour s'imaginer qu'une femme n'est
pas capable de 10,6 de calcul de
dissimulation de deux et on le sait bien
que dans un cas de mariage qui se
fracturent ça peut arriver donc je
comprends les propos de cet avocat on
peut pas dire par essence il ya une
femme qui dit qu'elle a été agressée on
ne laisse pas faire la justice
mais seront on décide qu'il faut avoir
de la compassion si si vous faites quoi
que ce soit si vous êtes un employeur
qu'il gardait vous n'avez pas de
compassion vis-à-vis de ces femmes c'est
c'est on rentre dans une spirale
infernale
par ailleurs c'est un fils qui va être
quand même compliqué à tirer parce que
si l'on doit ne plus publier tous les
auteurs un peu sulfureux dans ce domaine
je rappelle qu'il faut enlever loti gide
bain en matière de peintres gauguin
simone de beauvoir et jean paul sartre
ont signé une pétition pour la
pédophilie
ça va faire il là encore il va rester
tout pillé à la plage un fait non
j'exagère parce qu'il ya tout le monde
n'est pas concerné mais néanmoins si
l'on silo c'est pas vrai parce que ce
serait dire que tous les écrivains ou
des compagnes des comportements de ce
type mais néanmoins cela risque de nous
emmener loin les mêmes éditions stock
retiré de la vente il ya quelques
semaines un recueil de textes de gabriel
matzneff qui s'intitule un diable dans
le bénitier piété qui était jeu officiel
imart qui a retiré le journal demain 19
jeux on vérifiera qui était absolument
irréprochable juridiquement parlant
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire moi je
voudrais bien comment elle très
sincèrement je comprends pas tout ça je
veux dire je comprends pas tout ça et je
trouve ça allait même pas scandaleux
minable jeudi minable d'abord quand
adèle haenel se lève pour 10 c'est la
honte pour polanski janvier un moment de
la polanski et pas du tout pour défendre
polanski par rapport à des actes il a
commis jeudi une jauge très simple c'est
qu'on interroge par ailleurs anne elle
qui est votre écrivain favori celui dont
vous pouvez pas vous passer dit louis
ferdinand céline très bien louis
ferdinand céline a écrit bac à tétouan
massacrer les beaux draps
les pamphlets antisémites les plus dosé
à bonds qui ont jamais existé mais louis
ferdinand céline jeu premier à le dire
est un immense écrivain un des plus
grands écrivains de la littérature
française voyage au bout de la nuit est
mort à crédit si on ne commence pas à
dire que il faut distinguer l'homme de
l'oeuvre si on commence pas à faire ça
mais allons-y
alors je vais encore bull loin que
gabriel chose tribunal flaubert tout le
monde les gens de la commune allons-y
elle et elle est supprimée mois toutes
les oeuvres 17e 16e et compagnie
allons-y non mais je veux dire si on
devient eu un tribunal soit disant
populaire et moti pas ce que c'est
quelques employés de hachette et cetera
qui font ça mais c'est quoi ça mais où
va-t-on
où va t-on dans cette inquisition c'est
l'inquisition pure et simple
sachez qu on pose la question aux
internautes qui nous regardent sur
twitter marc pose la question du groupe
hachette at il eu raison de renoncer à
publier les mémoires de woody allen et
69% d'entre nous disent que oui
sur les réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux
sociaux j'aiguise à vélo on pouvait lire
ce week-end un éditeur américain sans
sur un livre de woody allen mais pendant
ce temps là on s'apprête à republier
mein kampf ce que s'apprête donc à faire
les éditions fayard
est ce que cette comparaison est valable
par exemple
deezer morin mais déjà quand andré fait
bien donner la parole à la fin parce que
je vais me faire que des ennemis sur ces
sujets là moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce qu'a fait hachette ne
ressortons pas les morts parce que vous
savez au vide et pline le jeune expliqué
comme ronsard que celui qui a le don
d'écriture et le prêtre des muses donc
il doit être irréprochable sur ce hors
série référendum alors sainte-beuve lui
a dit aussi qu il pensait comme ça où je
pensais jamais d'accord avec nommés
juges ont déjà les vivants dans les
jacky isabello vous êtes d'accord avec
art et jason les moi je suis pour ce qui
arrive à monsieur matzneff moi je trouve
scandaleux que comme le disait geneviève
fraisse monsieur polanski est utilisé
cette affaire de dreyfus pourri pour
faire sa défense personnelle à travers à
travers ce film vais vous de vous voyez
je vous ai bien fait de me donner la
parole à la fin je suis d'accord avec
françoise héritier qui explique que
notre société à cantonner les femmes
un rôle qui est un rôle qu'il fallait
arrêter et que non mais il toussait et
assez fortement lié et ce mouvement me
to qui a été notamment notamment qui a
pris son envol par l'intermédiaire de de
cette affaire de woody allen
et bien c'est vrai que comme à la
commune comme le lendemain de la
révolution on va vivre des choses qui
vont être totalement excessif je suis
d'accord avec vous et pendant un moment
dès qu'on sera pas d'accord on sera
conspué par les féminismes il est temps
que ça se passe andré il est temps que
ça se passe pour ma fille pour votre
petite fille et pour tout un tas de
jeunes lorrains de pouvoir c'est qu'une
femme normes et simone de beauvoir elle
a été malheureuse de halage malheureuse
mais ça n'a rien à voir
de faux ciel qu'elle a passé avec jean
paul st louis désormais les amazighs là
où les femmes peuvent être coupables si
moi je vais terminer dans mon rôle parce
que vous êtes trop intelligent pour moi
dans un autre c'est de dire en
communication on explique de plus en
plus que les entreprises doivent être
politique et les entreprises de plus en
plus elles défendent les choix
politiques de leurs clients et qu'à un
moment achète avec ses salariés disent
ce principe de précaution de ne pas le
publier nous pouvons faire ce choix
comme nous pouvons faire le choix de ne
pas publier isabello c'est un mois
commission et la morale nous ne sommes
pas vraiment bien défendre vos clients
ou les gens de leurs clients ce n'est
pas de la communication arrêter de
parler qu'au mieux les salariés de
hachette et s'est jouée le chat de race
que c'est là où les salariés de la
chaîne
primo et puis comme on attendait il n'a
pas été condamné
vous l'avez dit très très justement il
n'a pas être conjugé mondiale est
arrivée le plus grand c'est pile qui est
accusé par son fils mais comment est-ce
que nos enfants nous accuse de sa maison
comme ça sont jamais assez de servir
c'est pas vos enfants 1270 oriane
protéger les enfants mais vous avez de
quoi ils sont protégés enfants
commençaient à voir les régimes où les
enfants sont traités comme ils ont
traité commençait à parler non mais
jacky isabello par l'onu je pense que
j'ai mais oui je souvent la maison en
deux mi temps à se marier et je suis
d'accord voyons les envoyant leurs lois
là c'est de là qu'il prétend essaie de
soulever ses couverts et donnait est
belle ne sont pas tous ces sujets ne
vient pas il faut doser le film réalisé
je vais apporter juste quelques
précisions au débat le louvre âge dont
on parlait tout à l'heure c'était bien
ce stock et c'est le journal le gabriel
matzneff que gallimard avait refusé de
réalité assez ça en sport tas a repris
la question composé sur twitter dont la
réponse vous un peu étonné effectivement
c'est l inverse il ya une petite erreur
plus groupe hachette at il eu raison de
renoncer à publier les mémoires de woody
allen et 69 % des internautes nous
disent que bah voilà rassurés merci
merci infiniment d'avoir des battues
avec nous et à vous d'avoir commenté
cette émission vous pouvez retrouver une
émission sur les municipales à 11h15
demain sur lefigaro.fr et point de vue
reprend demain à 17 heures
[Musique]